so you were a derivatives trader then
you became a restaurateur
and then a software entrepreneur which
makes you i think a complete renaissance
man here on the show i want to start
with
the the booking platform that you built
you were in the restaurant business i
understand that open table
is absolutely hated by restaurant tours
second only to yelp in terms of content
that is probably accurate yes you've
done your research that is
about accurate yes and you and i both
grew up in the restaurant business where
both greeks
if people couldn't tell from the last
names my name is actually with kays as
well
but you grew up either your dad or your
uncle's owned restaurants
i if you grew up in chicago man you know
greeks
greek cousins there's always three
cousins that have a restaurant somewhere
or whatnot i definitely did not
really grow up in the business but i was
always it was like one
it's one kevin bacon away from you know
i literally grew up in it you didn't
work in the in the restaurants of your
own
the first day i worked in a restaurant
was the day we opened millennia which is
pretty crazy
and you came to the restaurant business
uh with the knowledge that every single
person you talked to said this
is the worst business do not go into the
restaurant business and then you made
the top restaurant in the country tell
us how that came about
yeah it was i mean that's for sure true
and i i spent over a decade as a
derivative trader
loved it started investing in the
internet as an angel investor in 1996
and had just a diversity of interests i
studied philosophy in college
and when well i grew up in a home where
my mom
wonderful woman great mom terrible cook
and so
wait your dad was the greek in the
family correct yes yeah so he couldn't
yeah they're like my dad yeah
yeah but he was busy too right and he
also didn't want to offend my mom and
all
that so there's a lot of complexity
there but yeah just suffice it to say i
grew up um
i grew up a very picky eater and it
wasn't until i met my
my wife and and her family who are
ethnically latvian
who are very euro and love good wine
good food trying new things trying new
cuisines trying ethnic cuisines all that
and it was genuinely at 22 years old it
was terrifying for me and that's the
irony of this
it's often the people who i think didn't
have exposure to something that become
the most passionate about it whatever it
may be because you're exposed to it at a
point where you're like how did i miss
this for the first 22 years of my life
and so i started doing what i always do
which is i started reading books mfk
you know fisher and ruth reichel and all
these kinds of
great writers there was a renaissance of
food writing in the early 2000s
and i started reading kitchen coffee
yeah michael roman
all those all those folks and
we we traveled a bit and we we ate and i
got more and more passionate about it
and this is all my wife will always
laugh because this is all her doing
um and and i get somehow the credit for
it but it really was her doing
in that it exposed me to all these
wonderful experiences
and then um we went one day to lunch
at trio restaurant in evanston and grant
hacketts had taken over there
and um it was just different it was
better
than almost anywhere we'd been in the
world and we'd been very fortunate to
eat all over the place it was 10 minutes
for our home
it was in suburban evanston which made
no sense
and the whenever you find something like
that it's like finding an indie rock
band or something
like that right where you go how does
the world not know about this
right and you want to immediately
evangelize it you can't shut up about it
and you're going to go deep you want to
find all the deep tracks all the live
stuff on
youtube etc i remember when i was about
14 years old i found the jam
and the cool thing then is that like you
know you some guys got all the vinyl
and you go oh my god they've put up 18
albums and you dig through and it's kind
of what i did with with grant
and with the food and
you know i didn't know anything about
the business really but i found myself
as i would sit down in a restaurant
counting chairs and tables and just
doing the basic
very basic math what is the total
potential revenue of this place how many
people can they put through
anybody could do this this is you know
back of the envelope sort of
modeling and eventually
um you know after going there for about
a year i
i asked him you know what are your goals
what do you want to be doing
um and i had backed some like yourself i
backed some small angel
startups and that's often the first
question i ask when i do
um and is what what's the goal here what
what do you see
yeah what's not what's not even what's
the goal for the business what are your
goals
like what do you want with your life um
because this may or may not be a good
fit for you even though you're the one
creating it
and um you know he was very
very singularly focused on
i grew up in a diner when i was four
years old i started cooking eggs
i worked for charlie trotter for eight
weeks i hated the environment there
he quit trotter told him you'll never
amount to anything
he got in a car drove through the french
laundry thomas keller was his mentor
but then he had this experience where he
he just worked for three days at lbe
when fran audrey was there
in spain in roses spain and
saw like oh my god like i can take these
traditional techniques and apply them in
ways that are emotionally resonant with
people in a totally different way the
rules get cast aside
and so as a young chef this was very
liberating for him and we found him at
that moment like he was 26 27 years old
he's given control of his first kitchen
and i just said to him one night you
know what do you want to be doing
and it'll probably not be here i'm
guessing in the long run
and if you ever want to do something i'd
like to help you
build a restaurant for yourself and he
asked me what kind of restaurant
i wanted to build and i said how should
i know i've never built a restaurant
before
and that was it like literally two weeks
later we we
started planning for what became
millennia and a year to the date of that
conversation we opened
which is great genuinely crazy everyone
along the way to answer your
question in a long verbose way everybody
i knew said
okay yeah you made a bit of money don't
flush it down the toilet with a
restaurant
did you make the money from the angel
investments in that dot com era
is there any big winner in that yeah
there was one big winner in that which
was funbrain.com which was a children's
entertainment website which i invested
in
1997 when it um was doing
you know a couple hundred thousand page
views a day and our options traded
uh our options software guys that i
found and hired
um hi mike zurx and paul hudson um yeah
they
uh they um made this
this game up math baseball for his
wife's fourth grade
um class and all of a sudden dial ups
you know this is dial modem days from
around the country started going it
going to the site even though they
weren't advertising it outside of her
classroom
so um built that up um and sold it as
part of the family education network
which was a 275 million
dollar purchase by pearson plc i was the
only person that had to say a vote in
the matter that voted against that
because i remember some greeting card
company sold for 500 million dollars
i remember that yeah yeah what was the
company it was exciting at home
something mountain
greetings blue mountain and i was just
like
and we had like we had eight million
students signed up and millions of
teachers and all this sort of thing
and and at the the metrics of the days
as you know are eyeballs
so i was like but we have more eyeballs
than them
hey everybody it's time for another r
crowd deal of the week
right now you can join our crowd's
investment in
boat setter according to the deal memo
boat setter
is the largest and only insurance backed
boat rental marketplace
that connects owners renters and
licensed captains
vote center's revenue grew a hundred
percent year over year
and more growth could be coming with 12
million private boat owners
in the u.s according to their deal memo
speaking of growth do you wish you were
in early on some of the best performing
ipos
of 2019 and 2020 well our crowd
investors were
and now you can join them with our crowd
accredited investors
can invest directly easily and most
importantly
early like i do as an angel investor our
crowd investors have benefited
from our crowd companies ipo-ing like
beyond meat and lemonade
or being bought by companies like intel
nike microsoft oracle and
uber so here's your call to action our
crowd's accredited investors
have already invested over one billion
dollars in growing tech companies
if you're an accredited investor you can
join our crowd for free
o u r c o-u-r-c-r-o-w-d dot com slash
twist
and review the current deals there is no
payment
involved until you invest that's
ourcrowd.com
twist to sign up for free